everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today we are on five of
our coverage of the 2017 u.s. chess
championships it's been a pretty crazy
tournament so far we've had fireworks
the entire way through and today is
going to be no exception why it's going
to be played by Ray Robson 22 year old
American phenom in 2008 he became the
youngest Grandmaster ever from America
so pretty cool to see him we've almost
been waiting for him to just take over
American chess in 2015 he got second in
this tournament it seems like he's
always up near the top some of his
tournaments he's playing so looking for
him to kind of break through he did lose
in round one to Nakamura but since then
he does have a victory in this
tournament so if he can get a victory
here that will push him near the top of
the leaderboard just be slightly behind
Wesley so his opponent playing the black
pieces is Alex Chappell have not had the
best tournament so far lost his first
three games and then ended up squeaking
out a tie in round four but if you
remember this guy does not like to play
regular openings does not like to play
conservative he likes play very
aggressive he does not like draws at all
so he's going to be looking for a
victory get back on track and see if he
can make something of this tournament
ray decides to go and start with pawn to
e4 pawn g6 upon d4 so say if you're
going to allow me to control the center
of the board I will do that with my pond
Bishop g7 fee and get it more of a hyper
modern defense Knight c3 upon c6 getting
ready to go for more that kind of con
and usually we see Knight to f3 here and
then after a knight to h6 maybe pawn to
h3 Bishop to e2 if you want to play a
little bit more conservative maybe
Bishop to c4 Bishop down here b3 castle
on the kingside that's usually how white
progresses in this opening rate Robson
decides to go a little bit different and
plays pawn to f4 I almost never see pawn
to f4 played at high level so always
really really cool to see new
theoretical openings coming
out these big tournaments I felt like
we've seen a lot of that so far just in
the games that we've covered in the 2017
us.just Championship pawn to d5
continuing with the katakana pawn to e5
very common just solidifying this pawn
chain really pushing material as much as
possible there's a lot of air in front
of the White King it's going to be tough
for McCaskill on the Queen side just
because black can easily start to attack
on the Queen side you can see if he
cancels on the Kings side there's still
a lot of room for black to kind of get
in behind enemy lines and start to
attack so if white decides to castle on
the Kings side he's gonna need to make
sure he does have a very very strong
attack
Knight to h6 as expected Knight here to
f3 and then pawn to f6 now I'm not
really sure why you would play pawn to
f6 if you think and out to one side of
the board your pawn chain really starts
to deteriorate if you move either your
pawns it doesn't matter if it's a H pawn
or your F pawn is going to be pretty
weak so I thought he might just castle
on the king sized it seems completely
fine to me but I guess he just decided
to try something a little bit more
aggressive and pawn to f6 is definitely
more aggressive Bishop to e3 castle on
the King side pawn to h3 blocking off
this critical square here on a g4 the
bishop could have even come down earlier
instead of castling
but that puts a stop to that Knight
can't come here so this live square
bishop doesn't have too many great
squares that he can come to right away
Queen to b6 decides okay can't do too
much on the King side I'll go and start
to focus over here on the Queen side of
the board why continues with Queen to d2
and then the Queen takes down here on b2
and this is not your normal poison pawn
variation that comes up in the night
Dorf defense that usually happens when
you have both knights on the Queen side
the board and you give up that pawn of
material in exchange for a strong attack
trying to trap that Queen on the Queen
side of the board and they usually have
to waste a lot of moves
that's not what this is Rae Robson
actually just says hey I'm going to give
up that pawn of material to try to take
this Queen out of the equation I want to
control the semi-open file with my rook
and then hey if your Queen
be preoccupied and not really in the
battle that's worth upon to me that's
what does rook over here to be won
kicking the Queen back to a3 and hit a
few options I really expected rook to be
three start to attack the Queen a little
bit Bishop to d3 than if he wants to
castle on the Kings side he can or he
could just play King up to e2 he does
have protection once his bishop is here
on d3 so some options here ray Robson
decided to go a little bit more
aggressive with pawn to g4 so he's he
recognizes his opponent is aggressive
and he's trying to be more aggressive
than that which i think is pretty cool
Knight to f7 Bishop here to d3 the pawn
takes a ray decides to capture with his
deep on I think it also seems good to
just recapture with your F pawn this
does open up this F file if he wants to
be pretty aggressive I think this does
that has both of his bishops eyeing down
on the King side of the board he could
just play Oh King to e2 swing his rook
over here that's gonna be fine you could
also castle on the King side connectives
rooks that way as well he does have some
options but decides to go and take with
his pawn from the defiled Knight here to
a6 saying hey I need to get this not
involved into the game but I'm gonna
have to use a couple moves here because
may be nice to see five could bring over
here Knight to c7 right now over here on
a six that's not doing too much on board
now we see white play rook to be three
for CIMMYT Queen's move Queen a5 castle
on the Kings side so saying that hey I
recognize I'm not going to have tons of
King safety but this gets my rook where
I needed to it can swing over to the
Queen side of the board if he does want
to double up on the B file or it can
just try to also control this F file
right here that's what it does pawn to
e6 and then pawn up to h4 I'm not even
really sure that with the lack of
defense that white has the black doesn't
even have a better position right here
you know he could have tried for
something else Bishop maybe takes on a
six and then if the Queen takes we could
see Bishop to c5 we're going
- eh rook to a3 attacking the Queen the
Queen comes here to see for maybe ray
decides to exchange off but first maybe
Queen to e3 he does have some options
each board just kind of says yeah I'm
not I'm not too worried about that we
just want to play as aggressive as
possible so that's what he decides to do
nice and t5 we knew that Knight needed
to get involved into the action and then
pawned up to h5 and I think he kind of
had three options h5 is definitely one
of them I think it's actually the
weakest he could have taken with his
knight on d5 and then he might come down
to b3
it is attacking this rook so giving up
that material and now Knight up here to
e7 you may say well you know this is
kind of weird because now that the King
is going to move how did you get this
rook back well he can definitely get it
back and that's because the bishop can
eventually take here on g6 and we will
have a fork and we'll kind of show you
what that looks like King here to a
chase after the pottery captures the
nice Queen down here to d2 after the
bishop takes the exchange of the Queen's
Bishop to d7 now after the bishop takes
in the pond recaptures then we see the
knight take on g6 we are forking the
rook so the rook is going to fall on
board but if we can't look at this
position white does have more pawns but
he's down a minor piece going into the
indie game I think this is going to be
tough for white and it's almost forced
all the way through there's not a lot of
other variations it could actually come
from that so I think this probably gives
him the highest computer rating but I
don't really like the move at all
another one would be Bishop taking on c5
and then we see the Queen take kind of
has to do that that would be Czech king
over here - h1 pawn down to b5 really
trying to control the Queen side of the
board pawn up to a3 pawn down here to a5
I think black has a better position here
as well h5 is just really extending your
pawns further than I like to in front of
the King but I also feel like this is
the craziest variation and gives black
more opportunities to get into a bad
spot even if this is not the bet
objective move for white now if we look
at black side of the board it seems
pretty obvious right now where he should
go
he has a rook staring at his face ready
for him to take Knight takes on b3 the
pawn recaptures night here to h6 I think
this is completely fun for some reason
Alex decided I don't want your rook I
instead once your Bishop doesn't make a
lot of sense to me but that's what he
decided to do pawn takes on d3 you don't
want to be taking necessarily with your
queen here after pawn recaptures I just
don't think this is nearly as good on
board pawn here to b6 I decided to go
ahead and take with his pawn which you
know I think that's fine now the pond
takes on h5 and Rey Robson does
something he's done earlier in the game
but it seems pretty crazy if you're not
really thinking too much about what his
strategy is he plays pawn here to g5
giving up another pawn of material he
lost his pawn on h5 makes total sense
just recapture here then you can play
King here - h1 swingers work over here
to g1 control this file try to attack
his opponent's king he says I don't want
that pawn I just want to push up and I'm
going to give you that material seems
like an odd choice so he's starting to
go down pawns in material if we continue
night here to h8 does eventually want to
come here to g6 so it can just control
more of the board Queen over here - h2
attacking the pawn Knight here to g6
queen takes on h5 kind of saw this
coming now that comes down takes on f4
does have protection from this rook here
on f4 or from the rook here on f8 so
that it's safe Bishop takes rook takes
down here nice to e2 attacking the rook
rook swings back here to f8 9 to g3 so
ray Robson he's down this is not the
position he's necessarily looking for if
you just from a material standpoint he's
not doing as well his opponent has a
double Bishop hair and he has Queen both
his rooks it's going to be very
difficult for Ray Robson to find an
attack that he continues
we see Queen to c5 King here to h1 after
the Czech Queen up here to e7 and then
rook to b2 and rooked me - any time your
opponent moves you have to sit there and
think what is their goal for what
they're doing are they trying to defend
are they trying to have a strong attack
are they trying to build something up
later on Rick - B - it's not defending
the pawn on a - that's not what that's
for as one specific reason and that is
rook over here - H - it's about a
telegraph it's possible because ray
doesn't have too many options on board
for him to go and play look to be too so
they I'm going to go and play Rick - a -
because of that we almost have to see
something you know after Queen here to
f7 attacking the Queen may be clinging
back here at age 3 we need to see Queen
here to g6 defending this square here on
f7 that's a critical square instead Alex
decides to play pawn here to b6 there's
not a lot going on on the Queen side of
the board why he decides to go ahead and
play pawn here to b6 kind of blows my
mind not totally sure but pawn to b6 is
the move Ruka be here - h2 attacking the
square here on H 7 and then Queen to g6
unfortunately it's a little bit too late
because Y just has so much more material
now you can start to throw in his
opponent Knight to h5 and then my
favorite move of the game is Bishop to
a6 it says you know what the pond to b6
was allowing myself to get the light
square bishop welcome to the game and
I'm not going to abandon that plan
regardless of what you did even though
you have a strong attack over here I'm
going to think about it I'm just going
to play Bishop to e6 even though it's
not doing too much so that's what he
does and then Knight to f6 check King to
f7 and then after Knight to d4 black
actually I think looked at the border
realized I've lost and he has resigned
in this position so congratulations -
hey Robson a crazy game from both sides
of the board and all at all rate Robson
although he started out the tournament
with one loss he's come back and he has
two victories and he's only a half a
point behind Wesley so he's in second
place
right here now if you look at this board
and say you know what are some of the
variations that we could see from this
position why is this so bad well we
already take a look at and see that once
this Knight moves there is a discovered
attack with the rook here on f1 okay so
well let's say we try to get that out of
the way King to see seven then we have
Queen to e6 and this is one of the big
things this night right here on d4
allows the Queen to come up here to e6
check and it's just bad from there we
have checkmate and not too long okay
what if the bishop just takes on f6 okay
well same kind of thing rook up here the
King moves Queen here to e6 this is just
going to be very very bad news now let's
take a look back and say the Queen's
going to come here to e6 well what if
the rook just swings over here to e8
tries to protect a little bit okay well
now night to h7 this is the discovered
attack that we talked about King up here
to g8 we see the rook take after the
rook takes now Knight here to f6 we
could see the bishop take that's fine
but now there's no way to really stop
the Queen coming up here it's just all
bad from here you can even see rook here
to g2 the queen is going to fall and at
the end of day it's going to be a very
easy game for Rey Roxon so exciting
match we've had five rounds so far
they've all been really fun to
commentate and just as someone that
enjoys chess I really like how these
players are approaching their game so
hope you enjoyed this video and I'll see
you guys in round six